good morning good morning allow me to
welcome you all to a special edition of
our weekly faith in life forum every
Sunday morning at 9:30 a.m. we present
leading scholars of religion artists and
intellectuals to help us explore matters
of faith and public life through lecture
dialogue and debate the mission of the
faith in life forum is to enrich
personal faith by expanding our
awareness of the important and pivotal
role religion plays across space and
time one of the particular issues that
the Memorial Church has sought to
address is the relationship between
faith and public service in talking to
many of our students at the college a
large number are people of faith they
believe in public service and activism
but many are not necessarily clear on
the relationship between the two this is
the same faith is viewed as something
personal and private while public
service and discourse is viewed as
wholly independent religiously motivated
citizens are often tempted to split
their identities and censor their
religious commitments to engage in the
public realm but as Professor Michael
Sandel encouraged us Friday night at the
Harvard Divinity School campaign launch
we must overcome the allergy of bringing
the language of morality and virtue into
the public sphere where the conservative
or progressive we can argue conceptions
of the right the good and the just
without having to abandon the religious
traditions that inform us from the
outset this is why last year we heard
from Karen Hughes former White House
adviser to George W Bush in the ways
that her faith informed her call to
service and in the same vein we are so
pleased to have two more former White
House advisors with us this
morning and the persons of Joshua Dubois
and David Gerken Joshua Dubois is the
former head of the office of faith-based
and neighborhood partnerships in the
executive office of the President of the
United States under President Barack
Obama mr. Dubois is a graduate of Boston
University with a bachelor's degree in
political science and then went on to
earn a master's degree in public affairs
from the Woodrow Wilson School of
Princeton University on the 2008
campaign trail of then-senator Obama
Joshua Dubois was in charge of the
religious outreach and is widely
credited with disrupting the
quote/unquote evangelical Republican
Party Union that many other Democratic
strategists wrote off as inevitable and
as immutable currently he writes a
weekly Religion column for Newsweek in
The Daily Beast and he is the author of
the president's devotional based on the
daily meditations he would send
President Obama when he served in the
White House we are so glad to have
Joshua Dubois with us on this morning
and look forward to having him back on
tomorrow night as he is our 2014 William
Belden lecture William Bell the noble
lecture this morning dr. mr. Dubois will
be in conversation with someone who is
no stranger to us here at Harvard in the
Memorial Church professor David Gerken
professor gergan is the professor of
public leadership at the Harvard Kennedy
School and has advised presidents
Richard Nixon Gerald Ford Ronald Reagan
and William Jefferson Clinton you can
read about his experiences in his New
York time bestseller
I witnessed to power the essence of
leadership Nixon to Clinton you can also
see professor gergan on most evenings on
CNN where he serves as a senior
political analyst professor gergan is a
friend of the Memorial Church and has
served as a wealth of wisdom and I must
say friend
me hence it's a real privilege and
pleasure to have him join us on this
morning to welcome our special guests
and our 2014 noble lecturer Joshua
Dubois we will listen to mr. Dubois and
professor gergan for just under 30
minutes and then we will open it up for
a short Q&A please make your questions
clear and concise so that they we can
field as many questions as possible in
our limited time together this morning
and now I present to you David Gergen
and our 2014 Nobel lecture Joshua thank
thank you Jonathan and thank you
especially Joshua for coming here
blessing us this morning we're delighted
to have you here you know we at the
Kennedy School let you slip away to
Princeton I'm not quite sure how but we
do forgive you I think it would be
helpful you rose to prominence and
became a spiritual advisor to the
president the United States at basically
the age 26 even by the lights of Bill
Gates that's pretty extraordinary rise
so tell him let's start with your
journey you have written in the past
that there were some long nights of
struggle with homelessness and poverty
and desperation that's right so I was
born in Bar Harbor Maine and then moved
to Nashville Tennessee where much of my
family is my mother and father
experienced a pretty rough breakup and
after that my mother and I were alone
she actually moved to Cambridge and went
to Cambridge College here but we
actually lived in a homeless shelter at
the same time worked her way through
graduate school there and she's just had
a phenomenal journey ever since she's
actually now a vice president at
Vanderbilt University so just a
wonderful story on her own she met my
stepfather who was a minister and
and we moved back to Nashville and I
grew up a preacher's kid from that point
on went to left Nashville and went to
Boston University for undergrad that was
one of the major reasons yes I just had
heard of his time and in graduate school
and I knew that there was a
transformative experience for him was
also for some odd reason growing up in
Nashville huge Red Sox fan to it and I
have to admit that that was a part of
the equation as well so went to bu
although I had grown up in the church I
couldn't necessarily consider myself a
Christian I I sort of understood the
bureaucracy of religion but didn't
really have a personal faith myself
until I came to Boston and went to a
small church here actually in Cambridge
kalbarri praise and worship center in a
Pentecostal Church Pentecostal church
met in the Tobin School in middle school
and found my faith at that congregation
around the same time I became interested
in politics a dear friend of mine Eugene
Schneeberger who actually invited me to
church also decided to run for City
Council in Boston and asked me to be his
campaign manager and I'm I can say now
that it was the worst City Council
campaign in the history of Boston but it
got Mike's my taste went for politics
identity you also became something of a
social activist went after the Diallo
shooting in New York yeah almost a
little bit about that well you know up
until that point I had felt much of a
call into the public square I mean I
wasn't active in the campus government
or n-double-a-cp but there was something
about that incident that there's a man
named amadou diallo of course who was a
young African immigrant
was accosted on a city street in New
York he pulled out his wallet to provide
his identification to a police officer
and the officer shot him 41 times and I
sort of followed the case as it
progressed and then at the conclusion of
the the the process the officers who
shot the alah were acquitted on all
charges and it just sort of broke my
heart and I just thought there was no
recompense for this man's life and I
wanted to do something and so I I went
to to the center of campus there at BU
and just held a sign with his name on it
for 41 hours and hours 41 for each
bullet that was fired and never done
anything like that before again wasn't
an activist but just sort of you know it
broke my heart and so I wanted to to
make sure that this man's name was
written down in the world somewhere
that's well you said you certainly have
a persistence about you you were turned
down sort of a formal note from bad to
go work for Senator then-senator Obama
and you said I think I'll go to the
office yeah so that's an interesting
story I was wrapping up my time at the
Woodrow Wilson School in graduate school
and doing an internship on Capitol Hill
actually for Charlie Rangel from New
York it was 2004 and I was in a
restaurant the Hawk and Dove I'm sure
you've seen it okay that's right pretty
noisy but this particular evening in
July of 2004 they were playing the
televisions were playing the Democratic
National Convention there was this young
state senator from Illinois who had
never heard of the floor with a very odd
name Barack Obama who I was giving this
wonderful speech he talked about all the
policy issues that I cared about in
health care and quality and so forth and
then out of nowhere he said and we serve
an awesome God in the blue states and I
thought my goodness this is a Democrat
who gets the language of values I heard
echoes of that great worship song our
God is an awesome God and I thought
you know for the first time there was a
elected official who was combining both
the the policies that really motivated
my desire to be in politics but with the
language and framing of values and so I
decided I want to work for him but you
know he didn't have a position open for
me and so I wrote a number of letters
and got a lot of form letter responses
and showed up as office a few times
until they eventually gave me an
interview basically now when you move
when he moved to the White House and you
he appointed you to run the faith-based
and neighborhood partnerships office
were you also then helping him with his
own spirituality well it was curious how
the devotion yes started well when I
first started working for him I wasn't
that close with then-senator Obama
personally at all it was just a junior
staffer in the Senate office and then we
moved into the 2008 campaign and again I
was just one of thousands of people
doing outreach around the country then
really this came about the devotionals
because you know one day I was kind of
in a regular morning prayer and I
thought you know this is a guy in
senator Obama who has all sorts of
supports around him he's got policy
advisers political supporters I just
wondered who was thinking about his soul
and so I decided to see if I could get
his personal email address I reached out
to my friend Reggie loved his body man
and I asked Reggie if he thought it was
a good idea to email a devotional to the
senator and Reggie said actually man I
don't think it's a good but he did give
me the personal email and I drafted up a
little note the first one was a
meditation on the 23rd psalm in a poem
that I loved by Wendell Berry called the
faith of wild things and just about how
to find rest and restoration in tough
times and I sent it off to him to his
blackberry about three or four minutes
he wrote back and said Joshua I don't
know how you did this but this is
exactly what I needed this morning would
you mind sending these every day and six
years later I've been emailing them
every day do you write them when do you
write them oftentimes on the Saturday
preceding I go out to a little dock over
the water by Reagan Airport and my wife
lets me spend five or six hours out
there and drafting up a number for
the coming weekend then I send them each
sorry so you you take your bar go that's
right but will you have all these
references to Bob Dylan and others or
cultural figures you have cool you you
sit on the dock how many books do you
have out there well I have my laptop
which is a media agency
I'll have a program a music program
called Spotify running on on shuffle
which you know pulling up all sorts of
songs from artists that I love Nina
Simone and Bob Dylan anyone else in and
so sometimes they will inspire and and
I'll bring out different books and
compendiums of quotations and so forth
you seem to introduce into these
devotionals strong emphasis upon joy
yeah and dancing that's right yeah
there's a there's one about Bob Dylan in
and quotes one of his famous songs and
you know I founded my time in the White
House and it's very easy to just look at
the task right in front of you but not
really zoom out and pull back and see
you know the the you know broader
perspective that this is a wonderful
time it's a it's a tremendous
opportunity it's a great responsibility
as well but a wonderful opportunity to
you know shape the policies that guide
this nation and to serve the American
people and there's a real sense there
should be a sense of joy in that and I
wanted to remind the president is he's
still turning to your devotionals he
still reads them and there's a little
prayer at the end yeah they always feel
included with the breath but it's your
own handwritten prayer I mean your own
yeah it comes from you that's right yes
so it's been it's been interesting and
people continue to puzzle about his own
how his faith affects him as president
he it's been said that you know he does
not go to church regularly in Washington
but he uses a lot of religious language
in his speeches it's clear that it's
there and this in his mind and it's part
of who he is
tell us a little bit help us understand
how it does affect him in the exercise
of the office you know I think it's his
faith is a settling force for him
settling in a steadying force and and it
allows him to really give have a sense
that life is bigger than even you know
the toughest challenges that he's facing
on it on a given day that when he walks
out of the White House for the last time
there will be some things that are
lasting his relationship with his
family's relationship with God and I
think it's faith reminds him of those
those constants then I think it also
connects him with some people who truly
care about him and not just because of
what he can do for them or his power but
they care about his soul he has a great
group of supportive pastors who come in
from time to time into the Oval Office
or every now and then I'll send a
devotional on their behalf and he's
grown quite close to them people like
Reverend Joseph Lowry the great civil
rights leader but Pastor Joe hunter a
great pastor from Florida and others and
so I think that's an important part of
his faith is his connection with these
people yeah Billy Graham used to preach
it and then he would pray with
presidents in the Oval Office says to
these spiritual figures they pray with
the president they do yes they come in
particularly Joel a woman named Bishop
Ashton McKinsey and Sharon Watkins the
head of the disciples of Christ and some
others do spend time in prayer with him
every year we have started a great
tradition about six years ago on his
birthday he hosts a call with you know
five or six pastors around the country
to pray for him for the year that was in
the year to come and so they they do
spend time in prayer we actually visited
with them with Billy Graham one time in
Montreuil in Montreat that's right it's
the first sitting president and many
presidents of course have visited him
but the first sitting president to go to
Montreat and just a tremendous
experience in theirs to see that a
wandering at Oak Hill that's right I had
the opportunity to visit with him maybe
three or four years ago three years ago
and it was it was a special experience
but but took me how does faith inform
what he believes is right in public
policy I think he has a driving sense of
protecting the least of these those who
are most marginalized
and I think that hasn't been informed by
his faith interestingly although he's
not Catholic there's a real sort of
knowledge and power of Catholic social
teaching in his life for a particular
reason you know when he began as an
organizer in Chicago he was supported by
the Catholic campaign for human
development and surrounded by all these
Catholic priests one of the one of his
great inspirations and that first year
in Chicago was he went to a organizing
forum where Cardinal Joseph Bernardin
was a guest speaker and in Bernardin you
know started talking about the seamless
garment of life where you don't just
care about people at the beginning and
end of life and birth and death but
about them their their human dignity all
the way in between and that was I think
a formative experience for the young
you've reflected a good deal on this
just because you've been there so long
now about what role religion should play
in the public square you know with
during the civil rights movement that
they're conservatives felt why are all
these church people getting involved in
basically an issue of public policy why
are they pushing their views as
religious people and today of course
people on the Left asked why are all
these conservatives getting involved in
pushing their views on abortion and
other things why are they it is a
there's an argument today on the left
that it's inappropriate for people of
faith to try to impose what they say
impose on others a particular view of
how life should be lived according to
their reading of Scripture so how do you
come out on that what's the right answer
well I think my friends on the left and
in progressive communities need not fear
moral discourse you know we are
inherently moral beings we may not all
be religious people or adhering to any
religion or the same religion but you
know we don't operate in the world in
the basis of you know 10-point plans and
facts and figures we operate and we do
the things that we think are right and
that sense of rightness has grounded in
some set of moral principles for some of
us that's religion and for others it's
it's other sets of principles and so I
think to really truly resonate with
people too
to to connect with their minds and not
just I mean what their hearts are not
just with their minds we progressive
communities have to be able to engage in
that that moral discourse and the
wonderful thing is there are so many
people of deep faith and values in what
even within progressive communities
among Democrats on the hill I wrote a
piece for Newsweek called the the secret
faith of Washington just just sort of
uncover some of this you know that
senator Amy Klobuchar for example is
this you know wonderful woman but you
know doesn't talk a whole lot about her
faith but you spend a few minutes asking
her what's most important in her life
and you find out that she is a person of
strong faith her faith has helped her
navigate her career in public service it
anchored her and tough personal moments
she talked about I talked him the piece
about how she was able to push through
her father's alcoholism because of her
faith and and so all these people have
these stories but they're afraid to open
their mouths and let them in so I can
the argument that faith strengthens the
individual that argument I think is
compelling for people across all the
whole divides it's a harder question
when it becomes my faith tells me that
on something on abortion oh let's take a
famous example Governor Cuomo the former
Governor Cuomo or the earlier one he he
by his faith said I don't believe in
capital punishment I'm against it but as
governor of all the people I think I
should respect the will of the people
and that wasn't interesting or and I'm
just curious about your own view on this
so I believe that when we enter the
public square we have to use arguments
that are accessible to all people those
of our faith and those who are not of
our faith and so we can't say I'm voting
for this bill or I'm supporting this
policy because you know my religion or
my God tells me so we have to use
something that we have to deploy
arguments that would be accessible to
people of no faith at all that said we
can talk about how our values are formed
how we arrived at that point and so I
think there's a nuance in line there but
when it you know when it comes to that
final decision
we have to use language and in framing
that would be accessible to any what you
would you is it appropriate for someone
who believe has a certain belief to then
sort of essentially try to persuade the
country of his belief or her belief
religious belief you know III think
outside of elected officials those who
are elected to represent everyone then
sure you know we we live in a country
where our Constitution protects the
ability for anyone to say pretty much
anything they want and if I want to seek
to persuade you of my religious
principles in and why my religious
principles should cause you to to think
a certain way then I'm it's my right to
do that I personally don't think that's
the most effective way to persuade
people look you Mitt Romney face this
course as a Mormon there was really you
know that was used against him because
he would bring certain set of views to
the Oval Office that would be
unacceptable to as well and so you know
I think at that level it's incumbent
upon those who are seeking office to you
know to make it clear that that they
will not be making decisions on the
basis of their faith their faith alone
of their faith alone yes right they'll
take into account other other
considerations is a democratic country
exactly you have to represent you know
you have to to some extent respect the
views and so at least at least try to
understand and respect it has been
widely reported you've had a sharp
defect I think he wrote about this or
referred to it in your in your book and
I commend this book to you can it be
found at the Harvard community can't be
found re coupe it's called the
president's devotional and Joshua put
this together from many devotionals he
sent to the president but use it you hmm
you apparently have a sharp disagreement
with the White House over health care
the Affordable Care Act and how it would
apply to Catholic hospitals yeah well so
the I talked about this in an essay on
on disagreement
I we had a significant difference over
the accommodation of both Catholic and
other nonprofit organizations religious
organizations that initially were not
significantly accommodated and they
would have to provide access to
contraceptive services when that's
something that they disagreed with we
have since I should note moved to a
place where the administration has moved
to a place where a robust accommodation
exists where a third party will provide
these services and a lot of independent
analysts say that that accommodation is
sufficient to protect religious liberty
the essay that was was less about the
policy difference although it's
important in religious liberty versus
women's often counterfeit values during
conflict that's right and when I saw to
illustrate in the essay was you know how
I manage difference because this was
such a big deal for the president I
thought it was going to shape his future
relationship with religious communities
into the future you know I and I've been
through other debates but none as
intense as this one I really sort of
took it personally
you know I brought it home with me I I
think I started demonizing opponents and
and really you know not putting myself
in the in the shoes of those on on the
other side until someone a very wise
person in the White House said reminded
me that as intensively its intense as I
felt about religious liberty and these
religious principles folks on the other
side felt just as strongly about the
protection of women's rights as I do as
well of course but and and that they are
not you know bad people they're not you
know I shouldn't have questioned their
motives and that you know we need to
fight as hard as we can on the playing
field but then leave leave it there and
so I sort of it was it was a growing and
learning experience for me just being a
part of that debate you also you did win
a major fight in the White House earlier
on about bringing inviting Rick Warren
the conservative evangelical and
Saddleback to come in to come to the
presidents and and and and provide a
prayer at the president's inaugural
first inaugural well I just say it
wasn't just me that was
I think it was a it was a moment where
we grappled with with difference in our
country and that if you have this
president who's very very strong on LGBT
rights and increasingly strong and
that's in and I think that's exactly
where he should be but can also engage
the of angelical community folks who
disagree with him and send a signal that
this is you know this is a country where
we can respect difference it's
interesting that you know just in the
last few weeks we've had a number of
debates around the same set of issues
from World Vision the International
Development Organisation and they're
changing shifting policies on LGBT
rights to I believe the the head of
Mozilla the software firm was just
recently forced to resign so I don't
think this is a question that we figured
out whether we can live in a country
where we have increasingly progressive
views and expanding equality on the one
hand but also you know parts of the
religious community on the other that
still maintained pretty conservative
interpretation you and I talked about
this earlier do you think it's possible
to build to with for each evangelicals
say on the left like a Jim Wallace or
you know or to the Rick Warren on the
right as a way to break through some of
the political deadlock in the country as
we talked about earlier before we came
out here you know Rick Warren on the
right it shares a lot of your views
about poverty and about the environment
not on other things yeah those two
issues yes as a bridge I think they're I
think we have such as you mentioned
start on the with the issues that there
there is a tremendous amount of common
ground on poverty certainly is one
environment human trafficking there's
been a greater degree of bipartisan
consensus on that increasingly and I'm
very excited about this around the issue
of criminal justice reform you know you
see conservative Christian organizations
like Prison Fellowship aligning with
very progressive groups and liberals to
say that you know we've got to do
something about the war on drugs and
this school to Prison Pipeline that's
affecting far too many young people and
so I think it's you know moving from the
sort of the 10,000 foot debates about
theology down to very practical
shoes on which we can work on together
yes I'm glad you raised this question
about criminal justice because one of
the most moving pieces that you've
written was a long piece in this week on
black men and you pointed out that
slavery existed in this country for
nearly 250 years but then sort of Jim
Crow kind of laws and then in effect
oppressive laws continued and you you
made the argument that in the last since
the 1980s we've had this dramatic
increase in incarceration and the number
of young men who are swept up black men
who are swept up in the in the system of
incarceration now exceeds the number of
slaves and 1850 yeah yeah you know and
obviously our population was a lot
sicker than of course but it still is a
stunning figure you know I think the
reality is this is a demographic in our
country a group of Americans who went
through a lot of tough times of course
that were not of their own choosing from
slavery through Jim Crow and in the
subsequent impacts and then around the
1970s we just sort of told these guys to
figure it out right you know in the 200
years of systemic disinvestment and
subjugation you know that's gonna have
an impact on anyone any any race any
person okay and then you know after the
Civil Rights Act of 64 and Voting Rights
Act of 65 and we we just sort of thought
that everything would be okay and it's
not okay and it was and a lot of these
young men did not figure it out it was
compounded by the fact that in the 1980s
we started this thing called the war on
drugs sort of a get-tough approach to
criminal justice issues that
unfortunately swept up a lot of
nonviolent drug offenders into into its
net a lot of folks think that that was
because of the crack cocaine epidemic in
the 80s and 90s but the reality is the
vast majority of arrests felony arrests
were for simple marijuana possession
vast majority or more there's a
wonderful book called the new Jim Crow
where a woman named Elizabeth Alexander
I'm sorry Michelle Alexander walks
through this phenomenon in detail and so
now you have the young men who are
saddled with felony records who were
removed from their families for a period
of time because of imprisonment and
we're not did not have the opportunity
to beat the sort of fathers and husbands
and so forth that they would have liked
to have been in their transitioning back
into society their sons are feeling the
same effects and you know it's it's it's
a it's a vicious cycle
now the helpful thing is that people are
waking up to this they're waking up to
the policies that we need to change in
terms of the criminal justice system but
also to the needs to really pay
attention to these young men this you
have a sense that they're all of our
sons all of our brothers in there if
they're falling behind our country's
going to fall behind but if we can get
them to a better place they can be
tremendous assets for all of us and
that's what the piece was all about yeah
let me ask you to help help us
understand this I went with a group of
students in January to New York and we
went among other things to the Bronx
defenders not an association which has
been fighting stop and frisk yeah and
they made a very strong argument that
stop and frisk applied aggressively is
quite intentionally a form of social
control that this was a an effort to
control the black community and to make
sure they knew who was in charge and it
was a views watch president organization
and I'm curious is that it as the
African American community looks back
over the last twenty years of criminal
justice 30 years is that a view that's
widely held in the black community and
is it one that you that you that seeps
into your thinking as well no I think it
is I would not go so far as to say and
it's an intentional strategy of social
control I don't think that there is some
Bureau of control out there that's
saying we need to figure out how to keep
black folks in line that said it sort of
seeps into the subconscious a researcher
named dr. Phil Goff at UCLA has done
some great work in this space and he
found that when most people look at
young I mean I mean kids young
black men ten eleven years old or young
black boys I shouldn't even say men they
endow them with much more sort of
decision-making authority
responsibilities over their own actions
and then we would have any other kid of
that age we sort of we we project upon
them our our own our own fears we forget
that their kids simply kids and and
because we've sort of created this this
idea this this monster out of them that
doesn't really exist then that's
something that needs to be controlled
because we become afraid of them I think
the most basic thing that we can do to
to roll this back it's starting to
happen around the country it's really
good to know these songs good get to
know these kids Geoffrey Canada the head
of the Harlem Children's Zone one the
most effective nonprofits in this space
is that it really boils down to first
knowing these gentlemen and then liking
them you can't serve someone you don't
like you know and and they're just kids
like anyone else they have hopes and
dreams and insecurities and fears and
sometimes they express those
insecurities in ways that may seem to us
aggressive or whatever that's just
because they don't haven't figured out
their own bodies yet their own selves
just like any other I'm certain I know I
was an awkward kid at thirteen myself in
and so I think it we must move into a
posture of really getting to know these
young men and then you know I think our
social services should flow from to make
sure yet cover to other points president
obama has started this organization
called my brother's keeper and he seems
to be in his second term speaking much
more to these issues of young young boys
and young men especially from minority
communities and what can be done and
Michelle Obama has said that this might
well be central to what he does after
his presidency I'm sure I'm just curious
where you think this effort my brother's
keeper is going
I'm very excited about it have been very
much a part of the some of the work in
in this space for those who don't know
the president has called together ten
foundations and starting to work his way
through corporations and faith
communities and others they've been made
an initial commitment of 200 million
dollars to invest in strategies that
empower these young men and getting make
sure that they are able to start life on
on the right path I do think it will be
an important part of not only his legacy
from the white house but what he does
after after he leaves office we focused
on five intervention areas I won't bore
you with them but if you'd like to know
more about it please please ask and I
think we're are subtly sort of moving
shifting to a place where it's not just
the african-american communities problem
in terms of handling these men but that
it's all of its it's a it's an American
issue and I think that's a good thing
that's right
so we values partnerships as a social
consultancy that helps foundations and
nonprofits that are secular than a
non-sectarian partner with the faith
community to solve big challenges and so
for example we're working with the
Robert Wood Johnson Foundation and
another organization on a project to
build faith community partnerships on
public health and another foundation to
build a national network of faith
communities on environmental issues and
addressing climate change and basically
these sectors are working on many of the
same things but they've never partnered
before we're helping to bring those
relationships together
terrific Thank You rific do I got we
would any reflections from you from the
pulpit
two wonderful guests see I want to give
them ample opportunity and time to
receive their questions so if you have a
question if you could just raise your
hand and we'll make sure we have a
microphone for you don't be shy oh
there's a microphone coming thank you
I've read very little or heard very
little about Michelle Michelle Obama's
faith background and I'm interested in
and what you can say about that still
respecting her privacy and and also how
the girls are being introduced to
religion in the family that's a it's a
great question the first lady grew up in
the church Anderson South Side of
Chicago
interestingly enough this is not related
to her own faith but she has cousins
that are african-american but a part of
the Jewish community in Chicago they are
converts and she has a cousin who's
actually a a rabbi
believe it or not but she attends
worship services as often as she can in
the family Candida can at st. John's
Episcopal Church there in Lafayette
Square
in Washington and ensures that the
girl's faith is cultivated through some
private Sunday schools and some other
things that occurred the white house had
been sworn to secrecy on some of them
but it is an important part of her life
yes please the relationship between
faith and morality in the public square
and public leadership I'd be interested
in your thoughts on the relationship
between faith and reality and that the
marketplace and our business leadership
and particularly through your fun to the
values partnership what opportunities do
you think there are for the sort of
great variable corporations in America
and elsewhere around the world to
partner you should know that Jane worked
very has spent years working with
corporate social responsibility
fellowship well I think it's a
phenomenal question and thank you for
asking it
I think there's tremendous growth
potential in that space that but I do
think that an increasing number of CEOs
and other folks in the business
community are interested in how to
incorporate values into their business
model my friend Jim Wallace has done
great work at the World Economic Forum
bringing this conversation to that table
in Davos we have begun gently consulting
with with a few fortune 500 companies
about how to to grapple with issues of
values in the context of of their
business I think the reason I say growth
potential is that these companies have
innovated in every other aspect of their
business model their supply chains their
hiring practices and so forth but when
it comes to community engagement and
specifically faith-based engagement I
don't think we've seen a wave of
innovation just yet there and so I think
there's tremendous room to speak into
that values partnerships we'll certainly
seek to do it but perhaps we could
dialogue about that further because I
think there's a lot of a lot more work
to be done I actually do have a question
something I would love for you to
address it and one of the things that I
touched on in your introduction was the
way that you kind of many people credit
to you with disrupting what was seen as
a immutable evangelical Republican Party
Alliance right and some of that has been
touched on professor gergan about issues
that we share in common
I wonder if you also could possibly
speak about the definition of what it
means to be evangelical and how so much
of that may have been
surrenders nor framed by media and the
like and how you were able to
distinguish it's a great question well
in terms of art but we obviously reached
out to diverse communities you know from
diverse faiths progressive communities
and so forth on the 2008 and 2012
campaigns and in the White House in
terms of our have Angelica outreach
specifically it was really rooted in
relationship you know we created
opportunities for the President and for
our senior staff and others to to
dialogue with leaders in the of
angelical community to go to church
together to break bread together and and
realize that they in fact had some
things in common and that was what sort
of slowly started breaking the walls
down there was just a sense before that
that you know they're not allowed to be
in the same room and so we created
opportunities for them to be in in the
same space the question of what defines
an evangelical I think is a fascinating
one and one that a lot of people are
grappling with right now traditional
definition would be sort of a belief in
the inerrancy of Scripture and and a
preeminent focus on spreading the gospel
go ye therefore into all the world and I
think though the ebb angelical community
is sort of unfortunately redefining that
at least some folks are too to say that
an Evangelic of someone who is an
advocate for issues of human sexuality
and and around abortion interestingly
enough and ironically that may inhibit
their ability to spread the gospel right
because they're closing all sorts of
doors that might otherwise be open to to
the sharing and the spreading of their
faith and so that's a part of what I'm
gonna talk about tomorrow in tomorrow
night's lecture is the fact that the the
the core purpose of an evangelical is
supposed to be to go out and and spread
the gospel but because of the way that I
think too many folks have approached the
political aspects of evangelicalism
their ability to spread the message of
Jesus's is limited please there's if we
have a zero microphone
yeah please
it seems to me that one of the major
problems in our society stems from
attention between something
quintessentially American which is an
emphasis on individualism and a
tradition that goes back to our earliest
history that fosters that and on the
other hand the need for community and
that tension between individualism and
community and the idea that we are all
in this together that we sink or fall we
sink or we drown we survive together and
it seems to me that that is very much
related to at least our moral
commitments if not our faith commitments
and I wonder if you have a sense that a
concern with those sorts of issues rise
at all up in the discourse in Washington
it's a great question and you know
reflect on that a bit if you don't mind
just might my very brief thoughts are
that is that that sense that we rise or
fall together is very much a part of the
the holiest texts of most faiths as well
you know notion of community of of
sacrificing for one another
and so I think it's woven into our
religious discourse no one has spoken
more eloquently to these issues than Bob
putting them right here I have some
concern yeah I think the tension you
described is right I have some concern
that that tension is being politicized
so that the right sees itself as the
holding up the banner of individualism
and the left sees itself holding up the
banner of community and people on the
right don't think they can support
community because that's the other side
and it does seem to make it's much more
difficult
to build you know bridges across which
are so vital to get us out of the sort
of political mess we had and and so you
know belief in community should not be
the preserve of progressives it's a
wider than that and in earlier days
people who believed in not individual
individualism also understood the
importance of community
if you read the Tocqueville it's woven
together you know America is a very
individualistic nation but one of the
things he was struck by was their
willingness to go help Bill somebody as
Martin when it burned down and everybody
got together and there was and voluntary
associations were central to what the
Tocqueville found in America and somehow
we separated them out and I think in an
unhealthy way he started things up here
going could you speak a little bit about
the history of the office at the White
House and the continuity of its mission
because I think it started under
President Bush that it was set up and
continued under the present
administration and how that affects the
mission of the of the office as such I
understand they have some funds
available also to further their their
their effectiveness which are outside
the oversight of Congress and so forth
and how this all works and that would be
great brief actually the first
faith-based office was a little known
fact started in the Clinton
administration under secretary Cuomo and
HUD they began a faith-based initiative
at the Department of Housing and Urban
Development to engage faith communities
on homelessness issues in on home
ownership as well but expanded
dramatically in the Bush administration
really rooted in the idea that there was
an unequal playing field unlevel playing
field and faith-based organizations that
wanted to compete for federal grants and
resources were discriminated against and
they the Bush administration studied
this and they put forth some persuasive
evidence to that effect and opened up
faith-based offices within federal
agencies to
to address that discrimination and to
level the playing field and so that that
focus on federal grants federal dollars
was the driving focus of the bush
faith-based initiative we've changed
things a bit in 2009 when we started the
Office of faith-based and neighborhood
partnerships changed more than the name
it's a subtle shift but an important one
I think the Bush administration did
phenomenal work in gauging faith
communities I have dear friends that
worked for that office in fact when I'm
very different in John deullyeo the
first head of the bush faith-based
initiative that said when I was on the
2008 campaign traveling around meeting
with pastors around the country and
asked them about the faith-based
initiative they had one very specific
impression that there was some big pot
of money somewhere in the White House
that everyone sort of knew about but no
one knew how to access that was WOW
pastors saw the you know the the the
federal faith-based initiative and so we
knew expectations were wildly out of
whack that there were far more
organizations out there than there were
grants available and so we had to create
opportunities for religious communities
to engage the federal government outside
of federal grants ways for for us to be
a resource to them outside of just
doling out money to these organizations
and so we created a set of programs we
called civic partnerships non financial
partnerships ways that we could support
their capacity-building connect them
with one another raise the profile of
successful efforts but not give them a
federal grant because there wasn't
enough federal money to go around
particularly in 2009 and 2010 when you
know we were in the economic downturn
that we were in so we started a program
called job clubs where we helped
churches set up job training programs we
started an effort to help churches
connect with in other synagogues and
temples connect with their local public
school and be a resource to their public
school all of these efforts were I think
a real resource to the congregations but
we're not about giving them federal
grants and so that shift in focus from
grants alone to non-financial
partnerships I think is the defining
difference between the bush faith-based
initiative and the Obama faith-based
initiative let me go back just a little
earlier where I think religion began to
play a larger
role in the politics of the White House
at which led to the faith-based
initiatives and that was for a long long
time most of our history mainstream
Protestant groups controlled our you
know the the people who were elected to
the White House tended to come from
mainstream Protestant and it wasn't and
it was more question private faith and
there was a large body of people
different evangelicals who stayed on the
sidelines in politics they thought this
is not for us don't get involved and
then and a couple of things happened we
had the prayer in schools decision which
they were alienated the a lot of
evangelicals and then importantly went
the roe v-- wade decision which also of
course in 1973 made a major difference
and that's when the evangelical said we
have to get into politics to protect our
values and our traditions and so the
first time they really got into politics
at the presidential level was when Jimmy
Carter ran in 1976 he was an evangelical
and they came out in droves in the south
to support Jimmy Carter thinking he
would be one of them and Jews frankly
were worried about it because they
thought he would be too much one of them
they thought it was gonna hurt Israel
well Carter turned out to be and the
more progressive tradition and the the
evangelicals who had poured out for him
and he had somebody in the White House
who was the outreach person to the
evangelicals they turned their backs on
Carter in the Democratic Party and
that's when Reagan hired our religious
and he set up in his campaign a
religious team to reach out to the
evangelicals and bring them over into
the Republican Party and that's when the
evangelicals began to move from
Democratic to Republican and it's been
it's never been the same sense and and
we've had this association of
evangelicals more on the right than the
last but both parties have been actively
now seeking out ways to get people of
faith to to come to them and vote for
them by appealing in some ways to their
religious faith in that led to the
faith-based initiatives that's the best
of his best of politics exactly
do I think there was one other hand here
somewhere I didn't say please well I
actually we have to call time now
unfortunately but listen please please
join me in extending our love and
appreciation to Professor David Gergen
and Joshua Dubois for joining us this
morning the faith of life form the faith
and life form is here every Sunday
morning during term at 9:30 a.m. we
typically meet up in the pew C room
please check your schedule on the
website so that you can join us we have
some other fantastic speakers that are
scheduled for the rest of the term which
includes Sharon Kugler the chaplain from
Yale University as well as Gustav
niebuhr former religion writer for the
New York Times and professor of religion
and media at Syracuse University will be
with us in a few weeks so check the
schedule and come out every Sunday
morning at 9:30 so that you can be a
part of wonderful conversation and
dialogue such as this that we enjoyed
this morning right now we invite you to
join us for some coffee and refreshments
until the 11:00 a.m. service you can
join us right in the memorial room here
off in front of the South porch to
continue this conversation and dialogue
and we also really encourage you to come
out tomorrow evening at 7:00 p.m. right
here in the sanctuary to hear our 2014
William noble lecture in the form of
Joshua Dubois and then his book Harvard
bookstore will be here on-site selling
copies of his book where he will is
agreed to sign copies as we have a wine
and cheese reception immediately
following his lecture on tomorrow
evening so get on the phone text some
people spread the word all of this crew
here get on Twitter and Facebook I know
how active you are there spread the word
let people know to come join us on
tomorrow evening thank you for being
here we'll see you over in the memorial
room